once again supporters of shia cleric
mogtada sodar occupy iraq's parliament
but this time they vow to stay put until
their demands are met
we reject corruption and corrupt
politicians sudan is a tool in the hands
of foreign powers he and his colleagues
work against iraq he wants to do
anything for our
benefit we won't leave until we kick
those corrupt politicians out of iraq
a pro-iranian bloc called the
coordination framework has nominated
muhammad a sudani for prime minister
these protesters have linked him to
former premier nuri al-maliki
despite calls for call by many officials
including sodor who instructed his
supporters to pray from violence
the protest is far from peaceful
the health ministry has confirmed that
dozens of people including soldiers were
injured when police fired tear gas at
the
[Music]
crowds everyone shares the
responsibility political parties the
political elite social forces and
influential figures we have to say it to
everyone and everyone must act wisely
with iraq in mind in order not to lose
again
saturday's parliamentary session had
been dedicated to electing a new
president
followed by the naming of a prime
minister
who would then form a new government
all that is now on hold
giving rival politicians a chance to
meet
but these protesters are worried that
mps could hold an unannounced session
to approve sudany
so now they're in for the long haul